ten years ago
computer vision researchers thought that
getting a computer to tell the
difference between a cat and a dog would
be almost impossible even with a
significant advance in the state of
artificial intelligence now we can do it
at a level greater than 99% accuracy
this is called image classification
given an image put a label to that image
and computers know thousands of other
categories as well I'm a graduate
student at the University of Washington
and I work on a project called darknet
which is a neural network framework for
training and testing computer vision
models so let's just see what darknet
thinks of this image that we have when
we run our classifier on this image we
see we don't just get a prediction of
dog or cat we actually get specific
breed predictions that's level of
granularity we have now and it's correct
my dog is in fact a Malamute so we've
made amazing strides in image
classification but what happens when we
run our classifier on an image that
looks like this well we see that the
classifier comes back with a pretty
similar prediction and it's correct
there is a Malamute in the image but
just given this label we don't actually
know that much about what's going on in
the image we need something more
powerful I work on a problem called
object detection where we look at an
image and try to find all of the objects
put bounding boxes around them and say
what those objects are so here's what
happens when we run a detector on this
image now with this kind of result we
can do a lot more with our computer
vision algorithms we see that it knows
that there's a cat and a dog it knows
their relative locations their size it
may even know some extra information
there's a book sitting in the background
and if you want to build a system on top
of computer vision say a self-driving V
or a robotic system this is the kind of
information that you want you want
something so that you can interact with
the physical world now when I started
working on object detection it took 20
seconds to process a single image and to
get a feel for why speed is so important
in this domain here's an example of an
object detector that takes two seconds
to process an image so this is 10 times
faster than the 20 seconds per image
detector and you can see that by the
time it makes predictions the entire
state of the world has changed and this
wouldn't be very useful for an
application if we speed this up by
another factor of 10 this is a detector
running at five frames per second this
is a lot better but for example if
there's any significant movement I
I wouldn't want a system like this
driving my car this is our detection
system running in real time on my laptop
so it smoothly tracks me as I move
around the frame and it's robust to a
wide variety of changes in size pose
forward-backward this is great this is
what we really need if we're gonna build
systems on top of computer vision
so in just a few years we've gone from
20 seconds per image to 20 milliseconds
per image a thousand times faster how
did we get there
well in the past object detection
systems would take an image like this
and split it into a bunch of regions and
then run a classifier on each of these
regions and high scores for that
classifier would be considered
detections in the image but this
involved running a classifier thousands
of times over an image thousands of
neural network evaluations to produce
detection instead we trained a single
Network to do all of detection for us it
produces all of the bounding boxes and
class probabilities simultaneously with
our system instead of looking at an
image thousands of times to produce
detection you only look once and that's
why we call it the Yolo method of object
detection so with this speed we're not
just limited to images we can process
video in real time and now instead of
just seeing that cat and dog we can see
them move around and interact with each
other this is a detector that we trained
on 80 different caste classes in
Microsoft's cocoa dataset it has all
sorts of things like spoon and fork ball
common objects like that it has a
variety of more exotic things animals
cars zebras giraffes and now we're gonna
do something fun we're just gonna got
into the audience and see what kind of
things we can detect does anyone want a
stuffed animal there are some teddy
bears out there and we can turn down our
threshold for detection a little bit so
we can find a more more of you guys out
in the audience
let's see freaking of these stop signs
we find some backpacks just zoom in a
little bit and this is great and all of
the processing is happening in real-time
on the laptop
and it's important to remember that this
is a general-purpose object detection
system so we can train this for any
image domain the same code that we use
to find stop signs or pedestrians
bicycles in a self-driving vehicle can
be used to find cancer cells in a tissue
biopsy and there are researchers around
the globe already using this technology
for advances in things like medicine
robotics this morning I read a paper
where they were taking a census of
animals in Nairobi National Park with
Yolo as part of this detection system
and that's because darknet is open
source and in the public domain free for
anyone to use
but we wanted to make detection even
more accessible and usable so through a
combination of model optimization
Network binarization and approximation
we actually have object detection
running on a phone and I'm really
excited because now we have a pretty
powerful solution to this low-level
computer vision problem and anyone can
take it and build something with it so
now the rest is up to all of you and
people around the world with access to
this software and I can't wait to see
what people will build with this
technology thank you
[Applause]